when the world rots we set it afire for
the sake of the next world it's the one
thing we do right and make those fools
on the outside the painted world is an
allegory for the outside it's a mirror
we hold up to reveal the truth even if
things are a little backwards think of
what this core vision just said when the
world rots we set it afire for the sake
of the next world a parallel to this is
linking the fire at the end of the game
which is very similar in concept to the
fire that burns down the painting the
linking of the fire chases away the
darkness just like the fire of re and L
burns away the rot both worlds have this
tradition of setting themselves a flame
to rekindle a cycle of rebirth however
consider this next line the Cobian also
says it's the one thing we do right
unlike those fools on the outside and
that's strange right because last I
checked those fools on the outside they
loved linking the fire they have an
entire kingdom devoted to it so why is
this core vien saying that they don't do
it right in the outside world that
doesn't really match up if these
parallels are correct then surely they
are doing it right let's try again
perhaps rot isn't the parallel to
darkness it could make more sense
instead for rot to be representative of
the neverending cycle of light and dark
a representative of stagnation and in
this comparison the father bleeds to
satiate the flame just like the
uncondition the outside and at the end a
new painting is
created but this time it's created with
the dark soul of man as the pigment just
like the first flame can be usurped by
the dark soul of men finally allowing
the world to progress to the next stage
I like this set of parallels a little
bit more don't you I am so terribly
frightened of timidly watching the way
like this like those form us on the
outside those on the outside can be
drawn into the painting and despair is
the one thing they all have in common
one such example is the first Corps vien
we meet upon our arrival we've all seen
terrible things but you're safe now that
it is your burden areand l will make a
fine home for you so go on ahead find
one for yourself a sweetly rotting bed
to lie upon there are three types of
core vien we talked about in this video
there's the humanoid ones that look a
lot like father
re and L there's the core vien Knights
and there's the crawling Corbin's both
of which look much more alike but the
name core vien is probably derived from
the latin word Corvis which means CRO
and these black feathers and what they
all have in common
we get no real clue as to the origins of
the humanoid core viens though they
always reminded me of this quote by
Nakamura in the Dark Souls one design
works where he talks about the crows of
Velka so this developer says about the
other crows he says I like to think that
they were humans who wanted to fly so
badly that they sprouted wings but
rather than their skeletons evolving
over time they instead twisted their
limbs into unnatural positions forcing
their bodies into a bird-like shape and
that's how I've always imagined them it
really reminded me of the contortions
they pull to grow wings these humanoid
Corgan's they're described as having
bodies souls and weapons that are
tainted through and through wretched
beings with no place to go so it makes
sense that they'd find their way into
the painted world and they rejoice upon
finding a new home here what sets them
apart though is that these are the only
creatures that listen to tales of the
painted world told on the outside by
their storytellers
we know that forlorn can be pulled into
the painted world we've talked about two
cases of that already and we know it's
possible for some beings inside to leave
also
so these core viens how the rock got
into the painting or they how the rock
gets out is there a deeper meaning to
their storytellers who go out into the
world and guide more core viens into the
painting by telling stories of the
painted world there's a few theories
that could spawn from this maybe but one
thing is certain they worship their
mistress of the painted world Freda the
first ash to enter the painting and
they're not the only ones this is a core
vien night a killing machine that is
functionally identical to those crows of
Velka that you saw in Dark Souls one's
painted world and the only piece of
information that we have about those
crows of ELCA is a little excerpt from
the design works of Dark Souls 1 in a
response to a question about the crow
demons Miyazaki says I always thought of
the painted world as somewhere where
things go to escape and the bird men are
no different they were originally
designed as worshippers of the goddess
Velka whose bodies were warped by their
devotion
I think this obsession makes them really
interesting characters so from the very
beginning these creatures were
envisioned as having bodies warped by
devotion and it's impossible to know if
Miyazaki still thinks of them as
worshippers of Velka but at the very
least we know that he at some level
thinks of Velka as related to crow
and in this painted world the devotion
of these crow like figures is directed
at another female de ethic form Frieda
their weapons tell us that in their
infatuation with sister Frieda the
korvia Knights swore to protect the
painting from fire and to this end took
to the execution of their own brethren
you saw their brethren before they were
the crows that were barely alive and
they were crawling through the mud
rotting wandering and kept in perpetual
terror by the stronger members of their
former family and it's one of the few
sane members of these sad crows who
tells us what happened here ah
Oh finally you have come Oh
one there is ash grant us how we make
the tailor stroll and burn this world
away my lady must see flame and you have
only to show her you are ash now you
know is it not fire that you seek surely
you've seen the rot that afflicts our
world but that witch fooled the good
father and buried the flame after we had
all made up our minds - we can learn a
lot from these little pieces of dialogue
first this one surely you've seen the
rot that afflicts our world but that
witch fooled the good father and buried
the fame after we had all made up our
minds - so this tells us that the core
viens made the decision to burn down
their world for the sake of the next
painting to come
this shows that they're very aware of
the nature of their own world and they
were rather central to the
decision-making here even on decent
terms we
the good father as they call him they
blame the witch Freda for fooling father
re and L into burying the flame but
another item description says that
father re and L and Freda chose rot over
fire together so maybe she didn't fool
him as much as The Cove Ian's would like
to believe the second interesting thing
is this line of dialogue make the Danish
troll and burn this world away this line
made me wonder who tells the tales in
this world storytelling is obviously a
big thing we learned that from the
storyteller Corbin's in the outside
world but personally i imagine these
stories coming from father arendelle
himself and my main bit of evidence for
that is when he says
notice how those quotation marks around
this phrase and shortly afterwards he
says and the quotation marks are gone so
here in Phase three of Frida's bossfight
I believe that our iandale is
interpreting the tale the way he wants
to he's saying that Frida's black flame
is the flame alighting when the ashes
are - instead of the world burning down
when the ashes are - so maybe he didn't
come up with the tales but the tales go
as far back as father our E&L who was
the creator of this world and lastly my
lady must she flee and you have only to
show her the painter that we've taken to
calling aria is known to the core viens
and clearly they'd know her as the girl
who will usher in the next world
born of what happens here so it makes
sense then that Frieda would hide her
away it makes sense that we would talk
about her next so subscribe and I'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]